So basically planning is hard.
So I assume reinforcement
learning is also hard.
>> So the results that we have for
reinforcement learning in POMDPs are
more empirical and algorithmic results,
they're not really formal results.
But still something that
people try to do sometimes.
If you have some kind
of robotic system or
agent system that's trying to figure
out what to do, and the world
that it's in is partially observable,
then you have to do something like this.
>> Yes, solve the halting problem.
>> Well, no, no,
getting the exact optimal answer
is undecidable
>> Well,
then is it decidable that
you can get it near optimal?
>> Yes
>> Okay, well, I feel better.
Why don't you stop depressing me and
tell me what to do, so
that I can sort of feel better
about this whole approach?
Sure, no problem,
I'm going to to ask you what to do.
Okay, so in particular, do you remember
we had kind of two main flavors of
reinforcement learning algorithms for
MDPs.
Do you remember what those were?
>> There's value iteration and
policy iteration, right?
>> Yeah, those are planning algorithms,
but for reinforcement learning in
an MDP, the two main branches,
model-based RL and model-free RL.
>> Yeah, sure, right.
Well, that was obvious.
>> Uh-huh, and do you remember
[LAUGH] the distinction between them?
>> Well, one used the model and
one didn't.
>> One learned a model and one didn't.
>> Okay, well, same thing.
You can't use a model if you don't
learn it if you didn't know it.
>> [LAUGH] That's true,
that's very well said.
>> So you learn a model and
then you use it.
Versus don't bother to learn
the model and just do it.
I think the little quip was,
the world is your model.
>> Whose quip is that?
>> Probably Rob Brooks.
>> All right, so we can actually use
this same kind of distinction, this
model-based RL and model-free based RL,
or model-free RL, in the POMDP setting.
Where in model-based RL you actually
try to learn the POMDP and then
you plan in it, and in model-free RL
we try to map observations to actions.
And we do that iteratively over time, so
we don't actually build the model, but
we do try to figure out, okay, when I
see this, this is a good thing to do.
>> Well can I ask you a question
while where here before we jump in?
So, one of the things that we know
we learned in AI class 150 years ago
is that if you don't
know what's going on,
you can often figure out what's going
on by taking specific actions that
guarantee you end up in some
state that you actually know.
>> Sure.
>> So even if you're blind and
you're trying to get to
a particular place in the room,
you could do stuff like, well,
I'm just going to go left for 15 minutes
and then I know no matter what happens,
I'm going to be against the left wall,
then I know where I am.
>> Yes.
>> And then I can do things.
Do either of these methods
do the equivalent of that or
an analogue of that?
>> Either could, in fact.
>> Well, okay, well, that's good.
>> Again, the guarantees on whether
things actually work in this space
are nonexistent, so it's not the case
that we can always say, yeah,
it's always going to do the right thing.
It's going to figure out the simplest
way of getting to a known state and
then behave from there.
But yeah, I mean I've seen both
these kinds of algorithms do
that kind of thing.
>> Okay, good, good,
well, that's promising.